Jackie buyer sets this movie apart from
other movies she's delivering a strong
well-crafted multi-dimensional
performance in a genre that has seen it
all and I think her performance and I
think the character of Anne is a first
if you're a horror fan this is sort of
an integral viewing experience the story
of Sister Anne coming up against the
patriarchy of the Catholic church was
really an interesting place to explore
and I really think that we wanted to
show all the different Dynamics when
you're in such a male-driven world and
and I think each character kind of had a
different relationship with Sister Anne
and a different way of expressing that
patriarchy the aspect of prejudice
against women was one that fascinated me
from the beginning about the story and
it was something I wanted to explore not
something that we hit the audience over
the head with kind of in a lecturing way
or preaching way but just in a way that
was almost common sense to me if you
have someone who's willing to do the job
and it has the talent to do the job
because she's a woman does that prevent
her does that negate her from being able
to do it in the church as it stands now
it does it was an excellent opportunity
to take a look at what if we have this
strong female protagonist that went
through this journey I think if we're
using art to hold up a mirror to society
right now and have a conversation I
think that's the conversation that this
this specific piece of art will evoke I
think people will talk about this so I'm
I'm proud of it in that way you know I'm
technically speaking you're not the
first female Exorcist
so the first in seven centuries
I'll take it
[Music]